what do you think of tick-tock
it's a thing i don't fully understand
there's certain things
i always get confused because i
generally try and make an effort to
understand
um most things and i don't find it that
hard to understand
things that other people find baffling
like trump voting
and i always argue very simply about
trump voting okay
uh look at it like this okay imagine you
work for a company
and you can choose between two bosses
one of whom is slightly uncompetent you
know borderline alcoholics say
but really likes you and another person
who's highly confident and technocratic
but you suspect secretly despises you
okay
you're gonna vote for the first guy okay
simple as that now that's absolutely
that's absolutely incomprehensible
to people in the technocratic elite
because they've always had you know
since i don't know
clinton they've had highly academic kind
of technocratic ivy league
professors who they see as essentially
one of them
so the whole behavior is
incomprehensible tip top
to me it makes totally perfect sense uh
there are a few things i find hard to
understand
tick tock i i think i understand
um it's um it's essentially video
twitter
isn't it i mean i you know but the music
aspect of it i think is really
really interesting because everybody i
think wants to make a music video of
their own life
and by making it really easy and
manageable so it's always interesting to
look at things like twitter and tech
talk through the lens of choice
reduction or facebook for that matter
um in that myspace gave you too much
choice
and people felt okay i've got too much
control over length of content style of
content
i'm not a graphic designer my page is
going to end up looking like
[ __ ] and then facebook comes along and
basically imposes some sort of
aesthetic constraint on you so there's a
limit to the number of variables you
have to agonize over
and twitter undoubtedly did that um
facebook did it
relative to myspace and i think tick
tock does that in
in in a different form uh by enabling
music
but in a way that you can't [ __ ] up um
so i think i i i think there's something
going on there and
a very interesting exercise in choice
reduction by the way
go online and try and buy a jaguar eye
pace
and compare it to the choice
architecture for the ford
machine of the mustang machi or the
tesla
now interestingly for products that are
designed to be bought online
you don't want a huge amount of
customization
why because because
this is a bit like the paradox of choice
it is the paradox of choice
uh conventional logic says that the more
choice you have the greater the chance
you have of optimizing your own utility
your own expected utility therefore the
happier you should be
actually if you give people too many
customization options they will almost
end up almost certainly end up being
unhappy with an element of their choice
so the jaguar one for example i went in
and just as an exercise i put in the top
of the range base model
and then three pages later i found
myself asked the question well i wanted
to pay 190 pounds for fog lamps and i
kind of went
i'm paying 70 000 for a car i'm not
going to [ __ ] pay
that you know 100 and the price of the
fog lamps was immaterial it was the fact
that i was being made to pay for them
and eventually i became so resentful
at the level of kind of addition now if
you go to the tesla or the ford process
it's basically five colors two kinds of
wheels two drive trains
you know um i think with a tesla you can
pay a thousand for the extra interior
with the model y
i think you pay a bit extra if you want
the third row of seats well fair enough
it's a degree of complexity i'm not
grumbling about that
but the extent to which the choice is
enough to make you feel you're actually
getting what you want and not paying for
things you don't want
but at the same time it's manageable
enough that you can actually go through
it in a sequential process
without feeling some sense of sort of
seething confusion or resentment
develop tick tock by constraining those
those guard rails is is helping people
to be less
[ __ ] there's only certain degrees of
freedom that you have and by reducing
that
the the maximum amount of shitness that
your content can be has been brought
down
you've got it exactly perfect we've
broken it we understand it yeah
and i think it's always worth that
probably 50 percent of my
obsession which is why i'm such a big
believer in this ergodicity debate
which is all about the mathematics of
optimization
under multiplicative dynamics okay right
okay but a very simple way of looking at
it right okay
you've got a little formula that says
one plus three one plus three is four or
two plus two
or four plus naught okay right they all
add up to four
and you can add one to either the one or
the three well it doesn't make any
[ __ ] difference right you can add the
one to the one
or you can add the one to the three and
it'll now be five
all right but under multiplicative
dynamics obviously that's not the same
rule right
you add the one to the lower of the two
numbers because if you take
obviously if you have four times naught
and you add one till to four you still
have
naught right what you want to do is add
it to
let's say three times one you want to
add the one to the two
because that way you get six okay rather
than say
naught or five or something right
now the reason that makes a difference
is that under multiplicative dynamics
and lots and lots of things in
human life are kind of more like
multiplication than they are addition
it strikes me as an essential absurd
um assumption of economics to assume
that utility is additive
okay that you utility arises from a
simple series of additive processes
that net out strikes me as bonkers look
at reputation you know the joke that
ends you shag one sheep
right okay we all know that joke okay
you know but do they call me dimitri the
boat builder
but do they call me dimitri that's
church builder but do they call me
dimitri the philanthropist
you shag one sheep right now that shows
that reputation is sort of
multiplicative
if you hit a big fat zero and one nobody
nobody nets out jimmy savile do they
nobody goes
yeah bit of a kiddie fiddler but on the
upside he did do a lot of work for
charity did some great work as a
philanthropist he did some great work
you know no you don't don't nobody nets
out to me
okay right okay
and so what's that making there's lots
of things in life are
more like multiplication over time
you